it funky from shop has bow man learn
dance get biscuit yes child please
accept me selfie sandbox today [ __ ] look
out kid
are you sure you're at the right rally
this is the rally to restore sanity what
do you hope to get out of the rally I'm
some nonsense
what'd you come out for today sanity
what needs to be done to restore sanity
a little bit of everything
that doesn't really get us very far what
would sanity restored look like to you
planning a clear national goal and a
government that is planning for the
grandchildren of voters who still
haven't even been born yet we've been at
a lot of rallies this fall this is about
the widest rally we've seen do you feel
comfortable in this crowd pretty much
the norm man I feel more comfortable
here then I definitely feel a lot of
Glenn Beck rally any kind of Tea Party
rally do you feel comfortable around all
these white people no there aren't a lot
of people in bunny suits in this crowd
do you feel comfortable being in among
the only bunnies in the crowd yes who do
you think is the worst offender and the
Nazi commie socialist fascist sort of
comparison parade the easy answer is
going back they gave me a million
gazillion dollars how would that be
supporting no crazy as Glenn Beck do you
think that the Glenn Beck rally had a
higher percentage of bald people than
the Stuart Colbert rally definitely the
only rallies that you hear about now or
all the ultra-conservative ones that
seem to think they speak for everyone
well I'm sorry but you know what they're
doing then a lot you know a lot of the
things Congress is do it now is what I
want them to do it's rush its liberal
it's anti Rush Limbaugh but aren't
weren't Rush weren't they I am Rand fans
pretty much is there any goofiness on
the left - um I would imagine so um
can't do too much as far as the media
goes I agree with him more so I'm gonna
find them a little more sane but
certainly there's nothing J give you a
good answer what do you think when
Olbermann says that Bush was a fascist
does that bother you as much usually I
guess I'm listening to it more in
context and it's not it's more for a
point and it's not it's more hyperbole
than it is a statement of facts if
somebody gave you a sign that said fight
the fear of MSNBC would you carry that
sign - um I don't know if I would you
don't see reasonable people putting
Hitler mustaches on people's faces so
there were no people with bushes
Hitler signs like there are as Obama's
Hitler I see what you're saying no but
really if if there should have been a
Hitler sign on somebody it probably
would have been him I hate to say it who
do you think is more insane Republicans
or Democrats they're nuts
what would be a conservative position
that you would consider a non liberal
position that you would consider
reasonable that would take some thought
man that would take some thought what
does your shirt say the front of my
shirt says liberal elitist on the back I
have to find what liberal elitist means
rational reality based fact-finding
science believing correct spelling
tolerant peaceful intelligent thinker
what are the libertarians doing app what
are we doing what we're handing out
literature trying to spread the
philosophy of Liberty more or less crowd
somewhat receptive it depends on who it
is try to remind the left's that the war
still going on the war on drugs is still
raging and no one's doing anything about
it
we hope to get the point out that it's
not all about getting your point out I
think you're doing that splendidly these
people are just pissed off and angry
Oh they've had nasty fights they need to
have a suggestion box when they put
slips of paper and saying I'm pissed off
at her cuz she did this and vice versa
we read them all on recent TV everybody
kisses and hugs and we start over yeah
how do you rate Barack Obama almost two
years in all right I think he's working
at about 80% who's but in power the past
two years well right now the Democrats
oh but the publicans turn everything
down the man won't so how is it gonna do
anything he can't get a vote no way from
them to be honest how can you not add to
the debt when everything is this bad
like stop spending every day we have to
spend money as a country so that's just
continuing the debt and but he's trying
to halt some of the stuff that's made it
this bad by spending more well why not
I mean if you're that bad in debt I mean
if I was that bad and that the only way
I would get myself out of debt is to
make more debt first and then try to
figure my stuff out that makes
absolutely no sense but I think it's
awesome